比特币的缺口回补现象是市场自然规律吗
还是庄家在背后操控
又或者是交易者们心里的预期在起作用
各位股东好
欢迎来到百万交易员
这期视频我们将会探讨什么是比特币CME缺口
缺口怎么形成
是不是所有缺口都会回补
所谓缺口是指这个跳空的空隙
据说只要有缺口出现就会被回补
比如比特币在2023年12月4日的缺口
52天后回补了之前2万7的缺口
回补时间为11天
在一般的比特币的标的看不见这个缺口
只要输入BTC1感叹号
才能看见这些隐藏的空隙
这个比特币的代码代表着
芝加哥产品交易所的比特币期货数据
也称为CM1
那么为什么会跳空造成缺口呢
CV市场在周末和假期日期暂停交易
而其他交易所的比特币
在这期间仍然在进行交易
当CMV重新开盘时
价格会突然跳到现货市场的最新价位
这就形成了缺口
正因为缺口会大概率被填补
许多交易者们利用这个缺口从中获利
如果价格没按预期走
他们还会选择扛单
等待缺口最终回补时再获利
在比特币的CMA交易历史中
绝大多数缺口都已经被填补
2021年6万牛的高峰后大幅下跌
留下的缺口随后也被填补了
再看看这个缺口被完美的填补
看着非常疗愈
那么有缺口代表一定会回补吗
也不一定
前段时间也有一个跳空缺口被填补的话
也情有可理
还有2023年3月的缺口
和20年9600和1万1的缺口
也并非完全回补
我们不能因为价格有缺口就断定他一定会回补
更不能因此认为比特币将来会回落到9600
来回补这个缺口
这种想法非常离谱
实际上缺口回补并没有一个固定的说法
但严格意义上来说
比特币在一般的时候都在震荡趋势
行情只有那20%
所以缺口回补往往是价格震荡的结果
而不是必然的市场行为
那么缺口回补的现象在你眼里是庄家在控盘呢
还是交易者心理预期的体现
又或者是市场中存在某种无形的力量
最后缺口回补并不是一个独立的交易策略
最多只能算是个额外的参考
而不是决定交易的主要依据
虽然缺口回补很常见
但不是每次都会发生
所以在做交易决策时
不能只看缺口
回不回补来判断市场走势
这集关于cm缺口的内容就到这里
感谢收看
这里是百万交易员点赞关注
不迷路
早当股东早享福
我们下期见